all right I said we were moving on from
the uh Hunter Biden cocaine story which
has nothing to do with Hunter Biden like
they're calling it The Hunter Biden
cocaine story even though there was no
connection to Hunter Biden I told you
earlier cocaine found at the White House
in an area where Public tours go through
and multiple Fox News hosts suggesting
it might have something to do with
Hunter Biden despite the fact that there
was no such evidence here is another
segment from this morning that's why I'm
only getting to it now Julie Banderas
interviewing former Congressman Jason
Chaffetz and she does the listen we're
not saying it was Hunter's cocaine but
we're asking questions that nobody else
is even willing to ask I think they
already know where it is I think they're
trying to wait for the DNA evidence that
doesn't happen in just a half a day or a
day but the Secret Service I do believe
knows at this point who this person is
I mean we're just asking asking
questions the reporters that are there
in the Press pool right but then if you
it's like when Tucker asks questions do
brown people make the country dirtier
and poorer we're just asking the
question look at all the other networks
for example all the major broadcast
networks last night they all LED with
the cocaine found at the White House not
one one broadcast mentioned the name
Hunter Biden now we're not saying it's
Hunter Biden's we're calling it for what
it is the president's son is a former
crack cocaine addict and he's supposed
to be clean he just he was given a slap
on the wrist for charges that should
have been felony charges why because
he's the president's son so preferential
treatment obviously is a very sensitive
topic when it comes to his son and
indeed cocaine was found in an area in
the white house where Hunter Biden has
visited so of course that's going to be
a question and there's no room for
joking about it all the other networks
making these stupid jokes about there's
no laughing matter crack cocaine
addiction is serious and this is a
serious drug that was found in our White
House
yes and I I heard one of those reporters
talking about well nobody got hurt what
about the development transport and all
of the other I mean that is just a
ridiculous he doesn't even know what
he's talking about so listen
um I got an email from a lawyer this
morning
who said you know David it is not yet at
this point
but it is starting to border on
it's not inconceivable that Hunter Biden
may be able to argue that some of these
statements are defamatory now Julie
Banderas is being sort of careful and
that she's saying we're not saying it's
Hunter Biden's cocaine which of course
is code for we sort of are saying it
we're certainly implying it if nothing
else but okay putting that aside
a lawyer wrote to me and said if this
went another step further Hunter Biden
may be able to uh Sue Fox News for
defamation I don't expect it to happen
but it is compelling stuff the latest
news by the way is that there is going
to be uh that apparently they have tapes
there are cameras that are going to be
able to figure this out and there's a
report from Reuters
cameras visitor log searched after
cocaine found at White House and that
now it may uh we may know exactly who
brought the cocaine I am not a betting
man you all know that I I really I
really just don't bet I just save and
invest my money I don't bet but if I
were a betting man okay my bet is that
the cocaine is not Hunter bidens if the
cocaine is Hunter Biden's
write to me tell me what I should do
I'll do something if the cocaine is
Hunter bidens I'll I don't know donate
to some drug thing or I don't know but
if I were a betting man I would say this
is not Hunter Biden's cocaine